que pierre guerlain professeur de
civilisation américaine à l'université
paris 10 nanterre
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
moi sur arte france
elle vous étonne cette nouvelle
tentative de donald trump
alors si on considère que comme fait des
numéros de cirque depuis le début ce
n'est pas très étonnant parcours ce qui
est un peu plus étonnant c'est qu'il ya
déjà eu des procédures qui ont toutes
échoué et on a vu que absolument toutes
les élites politiques des états unis
avait lâché tonnes même foxnews les plus
derrière tom may mitch mcconnell a
reconnu l'élection de baden donc il faut
chercher une raison
d'abord dans le narcissisme de de tron
qui fait un nouveau numéro 2 de cire
mais s'interrogeait aussi pour savoir si
en fait ce n'est pas une autre forme de
campagne électorale pour les élections
qui va avoir lieu au début janvier en
géorgie est ce que nous ferons pas
encore une chance aujourd'hui de voir
modifier les résultats du scrutin du 3
novembre dernier
étant donné que la cour suprême a déjà
statué par exemple lorsqu'une procédure
qui avait été lancée par le texas où
dire non c'est très peu probable
on va dire quasiment impossible même
s'il faut toujours se méfier parce que
quand on a des jugements comme ça les
gens s'habituent mains possibles qui
peut arriver
et les surprises mais très franchement
c'est très très très peu comme probable
l'intérêt de cette manoeuvre avec ajoute
brugidou yannick est de plus en plus
proteste se situe ailleurs que dans le
droit notamment dans le le débat
médiatique ou com se positionne
peut-être pour lancer une nouvelle
chaîne de télévision est ce que font son
propre os et ses dernières tentatives
est ce qu'elle trouve en écho auprès
d'autres républicains puisque vous
évoquez à l'instant les les prochaines
échéances électorales à venir
alors quand même ce qu'on note c'est que
ya une érosion du soutien dans le camp
des élus républicains
c'est particulièrement important que ma
connu et reconnu l'élection de
de bayda donc le soutient il le cherche
dans une base dans sa base dite
populaire mais plus vraiment auprès des
élus qu'elle regardait ce que vous
portez sur cette période de transition à
la maison blanche c'est du jamais vu une
telle séquence alors c'est du jamais vu
dans cette ampleur là il ya eu par
exemple en 2000
plusieurs semaines où on recompte à les
voies en floride
il y avait des manoeuvres d'intimidation
de la part des soutiens républicains du
candidat bush à l'époque qui finalement
été élu mais là que ça dure aussi
longtemps et qui est autant de recours
oui c'est c'est quelque chose de deux
particulièrement frappant
mais tous les acteurs qui comptent sont
préparés à la transition c'est à dire
ils ont intégré le fait que ben laden
allait arriver dans un mois et après
concrètement justement pour la passation
de pouvoir entre donald trump et joe
biden
quelles conséquences est ce que ça or
pour le mandat à venir de joe biden
alors sacré d'une gêne surtout pour le
début du mandat
mais les gens qui sont d'abord bail de
lui-même et des gens qui sont autour de
lui sont des gens qui sont qui
connaissent bien la maison blanche et
les rouages de la démocratie américaine
il faut voir aussi que dans un système
où les forces d'argent beaucoup
d'importance les élites économiques et
militaires ont déjà fait la transition
ils vont gérer les affaires avec un
autre président une autre équipe qui se
rapproche d'eux de façon moins haute en
couleurs que celles de toi mais qui sera
pas en opposition fondamentale dont la
transition chez les les élites
économiques et politiques
elle est déjà effectuée il ya quand même
des échanges ans on imagine à la maison
blanche entre les deux administrations
alors évidemment il n'y a pas d'échangé
du bureau de l'ancien président est le
président élu
[Musique]
on peut supposer que les milieux du
renseignement le milieu économique où
passent les informations et l'équipe ii
by dane de toute façon est très ancrée
dans le rouage de la politique
américaine dont doit y avoir des
secousses dans la barre à la période de
transition aussi noté que les états unis
qui ont un système électoral qui est
archaïque et totalement injuste avec 7
millions de voix de plus que son
opposant bayonne a failli ne pas gagner
parce qu'elle est très peu de bois des
cars dans les états qui compte est une
transition de deux mois et demi si
quelque chose d'inhabituel font un pays
démocratique qu'il faudrait réformer ne
voit pas les forces qui poussent à la
réforme
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation père gardant le professeur de
civilisation américaine à l'université
paris 10 nanterre